our cell is just like a factory where
the plasma membrane of the cell is
compared to the boundary wall of the
flat factory now unlike the boundary
wall which is made up of brick in the
factory the cell membrane is pretty
fluid and even the protein on the
membrane can even move in these sea of
lipids like a island so the membrane is
pretty much flexible in nature and in
this video we would look
Lisl for this fluidity and what is the
advantage of having fluidity or not
having or having rigidity so what type
of motion does the lipid molecules
exhibit inside a membrane so if we think
about a patch of the membrane so one
particular phospholipid can show lateral
movement laterally it can diffuse in any
direction but the rate is very slow it
can also show rotational movement along
its own axis it can also show flip-flop
movement like from one bilayer to the
other face of the bilayer so all these
possible movement can happen now even we
talk about the flip-flop movement or
transpiler movement we can see from the
outer leaflet to the inner leaflet this
kind of movement can happen and that can
happen with the help of several enzyme
like lipase whereas the inner to outer
movement happens with the help of
floppies and with scramble is the
bi-directional movement happens so
membrane fluidity and type of membrane
movement is dependent upon several
proteins as well but there is also
several kind of like spontaneous
diffusion happening now we should ask
the question what is the like how the
membrane fluidity can be experimental
data determined and then how scientists
found out that membrane is fluid not
something very solid and second we
should point out the cause that why
membrane is fluid and what
factors governments Luigi D so let's say
you have a cell like this in a culture
dish then you in the membrane is
unlabeled right now but you can
eventually label the membrane without
fluorescently mark the lipids so
eventually the cells would have labeled
membrane which is a fluorescent a level
membrane and then under a fluorescence
microscope you can apply like very high
intensity laser to bleach that region
out after bleaching out with high
intensity laser the region or where the
laser has fallen is totally like devoid
of Thorson's but if you wait for some
time and cross-check the fluorescence
over time then you would see there is
some amount of like recovery in this
fluorescence gradually as the time pass
so this observation asked led to the
discovery that the membrane was fluid if
the membrane was not fluid the nearby
membrane nearby lipid molecules which
are fluorescent cannot come into the
region and like try to recover the
fluorescence over time so the
fluorescence recovery after a flow photo
bleaching was one of the experiment by
which scientists found out that the
membranes are fluid now let's talk about
what are the factors that govern
membrane fluidity or membrane
flexibility so first of all the main
important point is the temperature so
with the increase of temperature the
packing of the membrane is where more
loose and membrane is way more fluid
because with higher temperature the
kinetic energy of the each phospholipid
molecule is increased and with increased
kinetic energy there is increased
possibility of mobility so with the
increasing temperature the membrane move
towards a solid - of food state let's
talk about the lipid structure and the
membrane fluidity
so the
proportion which is shown in the left
hand side is less sweet it has called
saturated fatty acyl chains now the
saturated fatty acid chains are such you
know packed in such a way that there
they could be like back very dense
manner so they are like behaving more a
rigid body than a fluid structure but if
you have unsaturated fatty acid the
unsaturated fatty acid would have a kink
now this kink would prevent packing very
dense packing and that is how our
membrane which has a lot of these kink
containing unsaturated fatty acid would
be more fluid than the other membrane
which has only saturated fatty acids
ammendment composition is a big deal in
terms of membrane fluidity definitely
cholesterol concentration is very
important factor the running membrane
fluidity now at lower concentration
cholesterol works like a dynamic glue it
binds to the kink and can kind of like
increase the rigidity of the membrane
make the membrane less fluid so it
decreases the membrane fluidity but
think about a very high concentration of
cholesterol when the cholesterol
concentration is high it don't allow the
closed or dense packing of the
phospholipids and that is how increased
cholesterol concentration can increase
membrane fluidity as well and this is
specially important for animals which
are raised in very cold environment like
in like polar bear like that their
membrane does not freeze because they
have very high concentration of
cholesterol as well now apart from that
we can think about the composition of
the lipid in membrane and the
heterogeneity of the lipid molecules in
the membrane lead to different degree of
rigidity in the membrane for example
some lipid you would find only in the
outer listed some lipid some variety of
lipid you'd find majorly in the inner
leaflet for example phosphatidylcholine
is majorly present in the outer leaflet
whereas for serene or NOLA mine are
majorly present
the inner leaflet also there are patches
inside the membrane which has altered
lipid compositions such as they have
like sphingomyelin
more cholesterol and Peugeot sterile etc
so that patch is kind of little bit
rigid and different from the nearby
region and they are also resistant to
detergents as well so these particular
regions or semi-solid regions are known
as lipid rafts lipid rafts are good site
for clustering of membrane receptors
several internal kinase protein GPI
anchor proteins and caviola so lot of
important signaling function takes place
in the lipid raft and there are it turns
out in a whole patch of membrane there
are small small portions where these
lipid raft
exists where the membrane rigidity is
high and they resistant to detergent and
lipid draft in terms of cellular
physiology and cell communication and
signaling is super important so in this
video we had an overview that what are
the factors that affect cell membrane
fluidity and what happens is like
membrane and an how specific really
rigid region inside the membrane works
like a signaling hub inside the cell so
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
give it a if you like this video the
video a thumbs up and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you